days of heavy rains have drowned out
these villages
the power of mother nature more clear
from the air
on the ground tens of thousands of
people here in malawi have been affected
many now homeless
[Music]
we've had floods previously but they've
never reached here yes mawanza river
could overflow but the people living
near it were the only ones affected but
not us living in hilly places it is only
this year that waters have displaced us
some aid is getting through but the
flood waters mean it's still hard to
reach remote areas
these flights are unprecedented that's
what we're hearing from
those that have been injured for long
normally
floods have
areas where they normally take place
but this time with anna
almost two thirds of this the district
has
have been hit
heavy rains have hit southern africa for
around a week now it's not just malawi
mozambique has been hit hard too
caught on camera by one of the rescue
workers
this man had climbed up a tree to escape
the fast rising waters
and in madagascar flooding has caused
electricity cuts across wide areas
thousands displaced here too
our house is flooded with water it was
flooded twice we were already flooded
the other time but we stayed there but
this time we had to leave because all
the mattresses are wet and our baby got
sick
authorities are now rushing to repair
broken infrastructure and help the tens
of thousands of displaced across these
three countries
while weather reports predict there
could be more heavy rains to come
stephanie decker al jazeera